l'éclectisme maîtres mots de la batterie
la salle guyancourt toise propose pour
sa deuxième partie de saison une
vingtaine de dates de nombreux styles
musicaux avec bien sûr du rock
on a beaucoup beaucoup de brokers on a
des suisses pour ces petits animaux
[Musique]
même jour à la fiche le 10 mars avec les
animait non retrouvera les psychotiques
manque ce qui avait été découvert lors
du dernier festival rock en seine
on aura également en rock on va dire les
plus anciens avec les wampas qui vont
sortir leur album là début 2010 est donc
après 30 ans de carrière voilà je vais
enfin c'est toujours aussi aussi
dynamiques sur scène
que ma guitare
rêver dans un cours d'eau j'engage
droite ça en du classique du hip hop de
la musique française mais aussi de la
musique du mieux africaine
particulièrement et kubel la batterie
c'est un mélange d'artistes
internationaux mais aussi locaux et des
têtes d'affiché notamment pour les
amateurs de reggae on aura aussi
l'honneur d'accueillir une des légendes
vivantes delà de la période des années
du reggae jamaïcain en la personne de
pablo moses qui revient donc avec un
nouvel album lui aussi qui a été produit
par harrison stafford le chanteur de
groundation groupe de reggae californie
qui est venu ici en d'octobre à
guyancourt les concerts reprennent le 15
janvier une année festive 2017 marquera
les 10 ans de la batterie
[Musique]